well there's a more general question of
course about uh um whether um the human
race or such
is something which is um
very special
or if on the other hand um it's just one
of
many such
species elsewhere in the universe or
indeed existing at different times in
our universe
it to me it feels
uh
almost obvious that the universe should
be full of alien life
perhaps dead alien civilizations but
just
the the vastness of space
and yes it just feels
wrong to think of earth as somehow
special it sure as heck doesn't look
that special when you the more we learn
the less special it seems
well i mean i don't agree with that as
far as life is concerned because uh
remember that we don't understand how
life began here on earth yes we don't
understand
although we know there are any evolution
of sinful life to complex life we don't
understand uh what caused the transition
between complex chemistry and the first
um
replicating metabolizing entity we call
alive yes that's a mystery um and uh
serious physicists
and chemists are now thinking about it
but we that we don't know
so we therefore can't say was it a rare
fluke yeah
which would not have happened anywhere
else or was it something which uh
involves a process would have happened
in any other planet where conditions
were like they were on the young earth
um so we can't say that now um
i think
many of us would indeed bet
that probably
some kind of life exists elsewhere but
even if um you accept that then um there
are many contingencies going from simple
life to um
uh present day life and some
biologists like stephen j gould
thought that if you re-round evolution
you'd end up with something quite
different
and maybe not with an intelligent
species so the contingencies in
evolution
may
militate against the emergence of
intelligence
even if life gets started in lots of
places so i think these are still
completely open questions and that's why
it's such an exciting time now
that we are starting to be able to
address these i mean i mentioned the uh
the fact that the origin of life
is a question that we may be able to
understand um and serious people are
working on it it's usually put in the
sort of too difficult box everyone knew
it was important but they didn't know
how to tackle it or what exposed to do
but it's not like that now
and um that's partly because of clever
experiments but i think most importantly
because
we are aware that we can look for life
in other places
other places in our solar system and of
course on the exoplanets around other
stars and within 10 or 20 years
i think two things could happen which
would be really really important we
might with the next big telescope
be able to image some of the earth-like
planets around other stars
image like get a picture well i actually
let me caveat that it take 50 years to
get a resolved image but but but try to
detect the light because now of course
these exoplanets are detected by their
effects on the parent star they either
cause their parents start to dim
slightly when they transit across in
front of it and so we see the dips or uh
their gravitational pull makes the star
wobble a bit
so most of the the five thousand plus
planets that have been found
around other stars they've been found
indirectly by their effects yes in one
of those two ways on the planet could
still do a pretty good job of estimating
size
all those kinds of
the size and the mass you can estimate
um but uh um but
detecting the the actual light from
one of these exoplanets hasn't really
built on yet exactly one or two very
very very bright big planets so maybe
like james webb telescope well james
webb
may do this but even better will be um
the european ground-based telescope
called unimaginative to the extremely
large telescope which has a 39 meter
diameter mirror 39 meters yeah they
equate on a piece of glass and that will
collect enough light
from
one of these exoplanets
around the nearby star um to be able to
separate out its light from that of the
star which is a millions of times
brighter and get the spectrum of the
planet and see if it's got oxygen or
chlorophyll and things in it so that
that will come um james webb may may
make some some steps there but
i think we can look forward to learning
quite a bit um in the next 20 years
because i like to say um supposing that
the aliens looking at the solar system
then they see the sun as an ordinary
star they see
the earth
as in carl saga's life phrase a pale
blue dot
lying very close in the
sky to its star our sun and much much
much fainter but if they could observe
that dot they could learn quite a bit
they could perhaps get the specialty of
the light and find the atmosphere
they'd find the shade of blue was
slightly different
depending on whether the pacific ocean
or the lamas of asia was facing them so
they could infer the length of the day
and the oceans and continents and maybe
something about the seasons and the
climate
and
that's the kind of
calculation
calculation under inference
we might be able to draw within the next
10 or 20 years about other exoplanets
and um
and evidence of some sort of
biosphere on one of them would of course
be crucial and it would rule out the uh
still logical possibilities that life is
unique but there's another way in which
this may happen in the next 20 years
people think there could be something
swimming under the ice of uh europa and
enceladus and probes are being sent
to maybe not quite go under the ice but
detect the spray coming coming out to
see if there's evidence for organics in
that and
if we found any evidence for
an origin of life that had happened
in either of those places that would
immediately be important because if
life has originated twice
independently in one planetary system
the solar system that would tell us
straight away it wasn't a rare accident
and must have happened billions of times
in the galaxy
at the moment we can't rule out it being
unique and incidentally if we found life
on mars then that would still be
ambiguous because uh um people have
realized that this early life could have
got from mars to earth or vice versa on
meteorites so um if you found life on
mars then some skeptics could still say
if it's a single origin um but i think
europa is far enough that's far enough
away
because
so so that's why that would be
especially it's always the skeptics that
ruin a good party but
but we need them of course we need them
at the party we need some skeptics at
the party yeah um but boy would that be
so exciting to find life
on one of the moons
of course
that'll just be any kind of vegetation
or life um the question of the
aliens of science fiction is a different
matter intelligent aliens
yeah but if you have a good indication
that there's life elsewhere in the solar
system
that means life is everywhere
yep and that yep
i don't know if that's terrifying or
what that is because if life is
everywhere
why is intelligent life not everywhere
why i mean you've talked about that most
likely
alien civilizations if they are out
there
they would likely be far ahead of us the
ones that would actually communicate
with us yes
and that
um
again one of those things is both
exciting and terrifying you've mentioned
that they're likely not to be of
biological nature well i think that's
important of course again it's a
speculation but uh
in speculating about
um intelligent life and i i take the
search seriously in fact i chair the
committee that the um russian-american
investor yuri milner supports looking
for
intelligent life he's putting 10 million
dollars a year into a better equipment
and getting time on telescopes to do
this and so i think it's worthwhile even
though i i don't hold my breath for
success it's it's very exciting but but
that does
leave me to wonder what
might be detected and um
i think
well we don't know we've got to be
reminded about anything we have no idea
what it would be and so any anomalous
objects or even some strange shiny
objects in the solar system or anything
we've got to keep our eyes open for but
i think
if we
ask
what
about a um
planet like the earth where evolution
had taken more of the same track
then as you say it wouldn't be
synchronized um if it
had lagged behind then of course it
would not have got too advanced life
but it may
have had a head start it may have formed
on a plant around an older star okay but
then let's ask what would see um
it's taken nearly four billion years
from the first life to us
and we've now got this technological
civilization
which uh um could make itself
detectable um to any alien live
aliens out there
but i think most people would say
that this
civilization
of flesh and blood creatures in the
collective civilization may not last
more than a few hundred years more
i think that the
bad people make some people say it
it will um kill itself off um but
i'm more optimistic and i would say
that sir
what we're going to have in future
is um
no longer the slow darwinian selection
but we're going to have what i call
secular intelligent design
which will be um humans
designing
their progeny to be better adapted to
where they are
uh
if they go to mars or something
somewhere they're badly adapted and they
want to adapt a lot uh and so uh they
will adapt um
but there may be some limits to what
could be done with flesh and blood and
so they may become
largely electronic
um
download their brains and have and be
exonic entities and if they're
electronic
then what's important is that they're
near immortal
and also they won't unless they want to
be on a planet with an atmosphere or
gravity they may go off into the blue
yonder and they and if they're near
immortal they won't be daunted by
interstellar travel taking a long time
and so um
if if we
looked at what would happen
on the earth in the next millions of
years
then there may be these electronic
entities which have been sent out and
are now far away from the earth
but still sort of burping away in some
in some fashion to be detected um and so
uh this um this therefore leads me to
think that um
if there
was another
planet richard evolved like the earth
and was ahead of us
uh
it wouldn't
be synchronized so we wouldn't see a
flesh and blood civilization but we
would see these electronic progeny as it
were um
and then this raises another question
because um
there's the famous argument against
there being um uh lots of aliens out
there which is that they would um come
and invade us and eat us or something
like that you know
that's a common idea
which so fairly is attributed to i've
been the first to say um and i think
there's a um escape clause to that
because these um entities yeah would be
say that they evolve by secular
intelligent design designed by their
predecessors and then designed by us um
and uh um
whereas darwinian selection requires two
things
it requires aggression and intelligence
this future intel design
may favor intelligence because that's
what they were designed for but it may
not favor aggression
and so these future entities they they
may be um
sitting deep thoughts
thinking deep thoughts
um
and uh not
being at all expansionists so they could
be out there
yeah um and we can't refute their
existence in the way the fermi paradox
is supposed to refute their existence
because
these would not be aggressive or
expansionist well maybe evolution
requires competition not aggression and
i wonder if competition can take forms
that are non-expansionary
so you can still have fun competing yeah
yeah in the space of ideas
which maybe primarily adobe philosophers
perhaps yeah
[Laughter]
in in a way right it's a
it's an intellectual exercise versus a
sort of violent exercise
you